mais que peuvent-ils bien faire je vais
la finir par être en retard à vous est
déjà là bonjour pardon
ma robe non je ne suis pas folle du tout
c'est un déguisement regardez
aujourd'hui c'est le grand concours de
déguisement dans l'île aux enfants nous
y allons tous monsieur du snop casimir
françois est le facteur je les attends
mais s'il n'arrive pas nous allons finir
par être en retard à casimir ne se passe
t'il un mail ils arrivent ils finissent
de se préparer tout ça je n'ai jamais vu
personne mettre autant de temps pour
enfiler un déguisement mais toi
incroyable disait on va pas encore c'est
pas eu le temps que veux tu il attend
lui que je distribue tous les costumes
moi-même accra mon pauvre ami senna
était trop dur non pas du tout c'était
très facile bon bah va vite des visas et
revient pas tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure
je suis fin prêt
mais en quoi avez vous voulu vous
déguiser en empereur romain ma chère
amie afin de restituer la civilisation
de rome tout son prestige et sa grandeur
qu'elle avait il ya deux mille ans c'est
fort louable mais ça m'étonnerait que
les romains et forte de tels chapeau à
vrai dire ma chère amie quand quasiment
ma porte le costume j'ai été un petit
peu surpris
enfin j'ai pensé que ma connaissance sur
cette cette époque était
incertaine ah bah tiens les voici ils
vont sans doute nous renseigner qu'est
ce qui vous arrive parce que ce que
c'est costumes et bien moi j'avais
j'avais commandé un déguisement de cow
boy
et moi une panoplie de mousquetaires et
voilà comment casimir nous habiller
s'est un peu trompé dans les accessoires
j'en ai peur m'écouter pour gagner du
temps nous allons appeler les enfants
les enfants vous venez très bonne idée a
germé vous avez toujours l'initiative
idée alors mettez-vous là pour cela
les enfants
monsieur du snob françois est le facteur
vont à un concours de déguisements et je
crois que casimir a mélangé les
accessoires alors vous allez essayer de
trouver les erreurs avec moi le facteur
est censé être déguisé en mousquetaire
louis xiii françois en cow-boy et
monsieur du snob en empereur romain
alors armelle
la couronne devrait être un monsieur du
snob déjà un premier point ensuite
magali
alors le glaive car le facteur doit être
acquis
jean-marie
manifs et
un françois doit être le facteur y voilà
les aigles et françois doit être aux
facteurs il est plein puisque tu es à
françois doyon du snowhall a et le b
lève qu'avait le facteur doit être à
l'emprunt robin une autre erreur si les
chats pour les chapeaux encore il ya des
choses qui va pas revoir il va
aux facteurs oui très bien ah voilà
factor vous êtes déjà nettement mieux
comme ça et toi romain
alors les pistolets de monsieur 10 par
françois
bon qu'est-ce qui est encore il ya
d'autres erreurs
non et ben voilà là cette fois vous avez
beau costume merci les enfants mais il
me semble qu'on n'a pas vu casimir
où il est seul il est encore tôt mais
c'est nous qui allons finir par être en
retard
tu crois qu'ils auraient mélangé les les
accessoires pour nous faire perdre du
temps
il faudrait quand même dépêché en retard
le voici au savez savez le grand
vainqueur du concours de déguisement
parfois quasi me fabien réussite on coud
donc vraiment casimir qui s'achève on
veut nous faire sonne que l'audace à je
me doutais que votre échec vous mettrez
de mauvaise humeur non j'ai apporté le
gâteau quand le président un du concours
avaient préparé en guise de lot de
consolation pour le perdant il pensait
que ce serait moi
il est trahi ou le gâteau des faillites
jour des cartes on peut lui pardonner
par hé oui mais casimir nom commence par
un non alors qu il se trouvait c'est un
gâteau à la crème bien aux fraises oui
mais avec des capes des cornichons et de
la moutarde
[Musique]